ANDREW BROGDON: Hey, everybody.
I'm Andrew from
the Flutter team.
And you may have heard
that on December 4,
we're throwing a big party for
the Flutter community called
Flutter Live.
Whether you're able to
attend in London or not,
you'll still be able to
see all the presentations
from the event since it will
be streaming live on YouTube.
Flutter Live is about
community though,
which means us hearing from
all of you around the globe.
So after the
presentations conclude,
the stream will cut to
me, live from London,
answering your questions during
the Ask Flutter post show.
If you want more
detail about something
that was just announced,
have a technical question
about the SDK, or just
want to see someone
do a bit of hacking
on one of the features
so you can see how it
works, I'm your Huckleberry.
And if you have a question
I'm not equipped to handle,
I'll find someone
at Flutter Live who
is, get them in
front of the camera,
and we'll answer it together.
The best part is, you can
get started posing questions
right now.
Just tweet them with
the #AskFlutter hashtag.
We'll take those along
with the questions
we get during the event and
answer as many as we can.
So there you have it.
Big party, the whole Flutter
community's involved.
And if you use the
Ask Flutter hashtag,
you have a chance to see
your question come up
in one of these little boxes
and then watch us answer it.
So fire away, and
we'll see there.